>>> THE MASK WARS ARE REFUSING
TO GO AWAY, EVEN AS CASE SURGES
WHERE IT'S HEATED AND HOTTEST,
INCLUDING FLORIDA.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE SEEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SHOUTING OUT SCHOOL BOARDS,
CONFRONTATIONS IN PARKING LOTS
IN ONE CASE, AN ELEMENTARY
TEACHER ENDING UP WITH STITCHES.
HERE'S CNN'S ROSA FLORES.
>> Reporter: WHEN IT COMES TO
MASKS IN SCHOOLS, IT'S SOME
PARENTS WHO ARE BEHAVING BADLY.
HAVING FACE TO FACE
CONFRONTATIONS.
AND EVEN BURNING MASKS.
THE TENSION AND DIVISION MOSTLY
FUELED BY MISINFORMATION.
>> LET THEM BREATHE!
LET THEM BREATH!
>> Reporter: IN TEXAS, A PARENT.
>> I DON'T WANT THE MASK WARS
FOUGHT IN THE SCHOOL.
I DON'T CARE WHAT YOU BELIEVE
RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: IN CALIFORNIA, AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER HAD TO
GET STITCHES AFTER AN ARGUMENT
WITH A PARENT OVER MASKS TURNED
PHYSICAL.
>> THE FEMALE PRINCIPAL STEPPED
IN SAYING IT'S TIME TO GO.
YOU STOP.
>> Reporter: THE PARENT IS
FACING MULTIPLE CHARGES,
INCLUDING BATTERY ON A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE ACCORDING TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
THE RAGE SPILL INTERESTING IN TO
SCHOOLBOARD MEETINGS FOR MONTHS
NOW.
LIKE THIS ONE IN UTAH.
>> SO, I TAUGHT JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL, AND YOU DON'T SCARE IN
ME.
>> Reporter: IN PENNSYLVANIA --
>> STOP, STOP, STOP, PLEASE --
>> Reporter: TENNESSEE AND WITH
YOU WI TOO.
>> STOP, THIS IS INAPPROPRIATE,
THESE FOLKS ARE YOUR NEIGHBORS.
>> Reporter: WITH MEETINGS ENDS
AMID FT SCREAMING PROTESTS.
>> NO MORE MASKS!
NO MORE MASKS!
>> I MOVE WE ADJOURN THIS
MEETING.
>> AND PUBLIC OFFICIALS OPENLY
THREATENED.
>> WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
NO MORE MASKS.
>> HOW TO COMBAT THIS WAR OVER
MASKS?
THIS DAD WHO SAID HIS 5-YEAR-OLD
UNDERSTANDS THE CONCEPT OF
WEARING FACE COVERINGS.
>> IT'S DISAPPOINTING THAT MORE
ADULTS AROUND HERE CAN'T SEEM TO
GRASP IT IS PLEADING FOR
CIVILITY IN THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION.
>> CNN, HOUSTON.
>> ROSA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
AND I WANT TO BRING IN ANNA
NAVARRO AND SCOTT JENNINGS.
THEY NEVER HAVE MUCH TO SAY
ABOUT ANYTHING.
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT WAS SARCASM, THEY ARE
FEISTY AND OPINIONATED, WHICH IS
WHY YOU ARE HERE, WE LOVE YOU
GUYS.
ANNA, IT'S CRAZY, THE BATTLE
OVER MASKS IN SCHOOLS.
THEY ARE NOT LETTING UP, EVEN AS
CASES AND DEATHS ARE RISING.
WHY IS IT SO HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
REALIZE IT'S REALLY, THIS IS THE
BEST WAY TO KEEP OUR KIDS SAFE
NOW?
>> DON, BECAUSE YOU KNOW, THEY
ARE, THEY ARE IN ZONE WHERE THEY
THINK IT'S A CRUSADE FOR
PERSONAL FREEDOM.
AND THEY JUST CAN'T GET AWAY
FROM IT.
AND INSTEAD OF LOOKING NUMBERS
AND THE STATISTICS, INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT THE RISE IN CASES,
THE RISE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
THE RISE IF IN DEATHS, THEY ARE
DOING THINGS LIKE LISTENING TO
POLITICIANS WHO ARE EXPLOITING
THE SUBJECT MATTER FOR POLITICAL
GAIN.
WHICH IS, I FRANKLY THINK,
IMMORALE AND WE ARE SEEING MORE
AND MORE CRUISE LINES LIKE
DISNEY ARE SAYING, NO,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU ARE
TELLING US, POLITICIAN ANS WE
ARE GOING TO REQUIRE
VACCINATIONS AND MASKS.
AND AIRLINES ARE EXTENDING
THE -- THE FAA EXTENDED THE MASK
MANDATE AND THE BIGGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN PLACES LIKE
FLORIDA, MY STATE, ARE IMPOSING
MASK MANDATES FOR THE SCHOOLS
AND I SAY, LET US ALLOW THE
EXPERTS.
LET'S ALLOW THE EDUCATORS, THE
SCIENTISTS TO SET THE STANDARDS,
NOT SOME GOVERNOR ON OR SOME
POLITICIAN RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION, OR FOR THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION.
>> YOU MENTION THAT, BECAUSE
THERE'S A NEW QUINNIPIAC POLE
THAT SHOWS 60% OF FLORIDA
RESIDENTS SUPPORT WEARING MASKS
FOR STUDENTS, TEACHERS STAFF IN
SCHOOLS.
WHEN DeSANTIS SAID THAT HE WANTS
THEM TO CHOOSE FOR THEMSELVES.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THEY WANT MANDATES.
>> ONE OF THE CLEAREST BATTLE L
TO SHOW YOU ARE ONE OF THEM IS
ON THE MASK ISSUE.
AS IT RELATES TO THE PARENTS
THAT ARE UPSET, I THINK IT'S
MORE COMPLICATED THAN SIMPLE IS
POLITICS.
I WAS READING IN A ARTICLE THIS
WEEKEND ABOUT THE CDC DATA THAT
K
CAME OUT.
AND IT'S CALLED THE SCIENCE OF
MASKS REMAINS UNCERTAIN AT
SCHOOL.
IT MAKES A COMPELLING CASE ABOUT
THERE BEING QUESTIONS OF IF IT'S
BEEN AS EFFECTIVE AS YOU HAVE
BEEN LED TO BELIEVE.
AND THERE ARE PARENTS SAYING I
HAVE QUESTIONS AND THEY ARE
BEING TOLD TO SIT DOWN AND SHUT
UP.
I THINK VIOLENCE IS WRONG.
THE STORIES WHERE PEOPLE ARE YOU
HITTING EACH OTHER AND HAVING
ALTER I
ALTERCATIONS, IT'S CRAZY AND
SHOULD NOT BE OCCURRING.
BUT I THINK SCHOOLS AND PEOPLE
IN CHARGE IN THE AREAS SHOULD BE
TELLING PARENTS WHOSE KIDS ARE
IN THE SCHOOLS, SIT DOWN, SHUT
UP, YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO ASK A
QUESTION OR HAVE AN OPINION.
THERE HAS TO BE A MIDDLE GROUND
THAT QUESTIONS CAN BE ASKED,
THAT BY THE WAY HERE IS BASED ON
CDC DATA, WITHOUT PARENTS
FEELING LIKE THEIR OPINIONS ARE
NOT VALID.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT DATA THAT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT, IN NEW
YORK MAGAZINE.
EVERY DATA FROM EVERY EXPERT
SHOWS THAT MASKS ARE EFFECTIVE
IN CUTTING DOWN THE TRANSMISSION
OF THE VIRUS.
ESPECIALLY IF TWO PEOPLE ARE
WEARING IT.
IF ONE PERSON IS WEARING IT, NOT
SO MUCH, BECAUSE THE OTHER
PERSON CAN SPREAD IT.
IF BOTH ARE WEARING IT AND
EVERYONE IS WEARING IT, IT SHOWS
THAT IT'S QUITE EFFECTIVE.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE FAKE
INFORMATION.
>> I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO READ
IT --
>> I WILL READ IT.
I HAVE A SUBSCRIPTION TO NEW
YORK MAGAZINE.
I HAVE SEEN THE STUDIES FROM NOT
JUST MAGAZINE ARTICLES BUT
EXPERTS WHO ACTUALLY, IT'S THEIR
JOB BE TO STUDY THAT.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
HOSPITALS THEY WEAR MASKS FOR A
REASON.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WORK.
SURGEONS WEAR MASKS.
FRONT LINE WORKERS WEAR MASKS.
>> I HAVE SPOKEN TO DOCTORS IN
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS AND I CAN
TELL YOU IN THE FIRST VARIANT,
THERE WAS NOT THE LEVEL OF
CHILDREN AFFECTED THAT THERE IS
RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW MY BEST FRIEND HIS
HUSBAND WORKS AT MIAMI
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL, THEY ARE
FULL WITH COVID CASES RIGHT NOW
IN A WAY THEY WERE NOT BEFORE.
WE ALL KNOW IT AND HEAR IT FROM
PLACES LIKE ARKANSAS.
WE HEAR IT FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY THAT THIS IS HAPPENING.
THESE ARE NOT FAKE A CASES.
AND SO, I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
WE AS ADULTS ARE ACTING LIKE
ANIMALS INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
PROTECT THOSE THAT ARE UNDER 12
WHO ARE DEPENDING ON US TO
PROTECT THEM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
PROTECT THEMSELVES.
>> BUT EVEN IF YOU SAY, LOOK,
SCOTT, IF YOU SAY AS EFFECTIVE.
LET'S JUST SAY IT HAS SOME
PERCENTAGE OF EFFECTIVENESS.
THEN, WHAT'S THE POINT?
EVEN IF IT HAS 20 OR 30% OR 40%?
IT STILL HELPS.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO PROTECT
THE LEAST OF THESE, ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN WHO CANNOT GET A
VACCINE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE QUESTIONING
OF IT, ESPECIALLY SINCE SCIENCE
IS SCIENCE.
>> AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
DISCUSSED IT.
I HAVE BEEN A RULE FOLLOWER THE
ENTIRE TIME.
I SORT OF BELIEVE THAT --
>> EXCEPT YOU HAVE NOT BEEN
DOING WHAT WE HAVE ALL BEEN
DOING, WHICH IS GAINING WEIGHT.
I DON'T TRUST YOU.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, THAT'S RIGHT.
I'M GOING THE OTHER WAY.
>> HE IS DOING INTERMITTENT
FASTING AND WE ARE DOING
INTERMITTENT EATING.
>> GO ON.
>> BUT, YEAH, THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO
HAVE RAISED AND I THINK SOME
PARENTS LATCHED TO THIS, WHAT
ARE THE LONG-TERM IMPACTS OF
SORT OF, ENFORCED MASKING OF THE
YOUNG CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON THE
LEARNING.
.
>> WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON THE --
ETCETERA.
BUT I THINK PARENTS HAVE LOOKED
AND SAID, I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AND THEN IF YOU LAYER ON
TOP OF THAT, THE POLITICAL VIEWS
AND YOU LAYER ON TOP OF THAT,
SOME SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR
TELLING THEM TO SIT DOWN AND
SHUT UP IN A PTA MEETING YOU SEE
HOW IT'S A RECIPE FOR ALL THE
STUFF BOILING OVER.
I AGREE, I DON'T THINK WE NEED
VIOLENT INTERACTION.
BUT WE NEED NMORE DIALOG AND
COLLABORATION AND PART OF THE
ISSUE IS PEOPLE FEELING LIKE
THEIR VOICES ARE NOT BEING
HEARD.
>> I FEEL YOU.
>> THAT LEADS TO ESCALATION.
>> HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT THE
VOICES ARE NOT BEING HEARD WHEN
YOU SEE MEETING AFTER MEETING
WHERE BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE
ARE AIRING OUT THEIR OPINIONS.
AND LOOK, YOU AND I GREW UP IN A
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHERE LOCAL
CONTROL WAS A CENTRAL BASTION OF
BEING REPRESENT ARE C-- BEING
REPUBLICAN AND NOW WE HAVE
GO
GOVERNORS THAT ARE USING THE
GOVERNORSHIP AS A PLATFORM TO
BULLY LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS, IT'S
SIMPLY WRONG AND IT IS AGAINST
THE REPUBLICAN TENANTS THAT YOU
AND I GREW UP WITH OVER LOCAL
CONTROL.
>> SCOTT, I KNOW YOU WANT TO
RESPOND, HERE IS WHAT I HAVE TO
SAY BEFORE YOU RESPOND AND IF
YOU COULD DO IT QUICKLY.
ALL THE POINTS YOU MENTIONED,
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO DISCUSS
IT, HOW IT AFFECTS CHILDREN OR
WHATEVER.
IF A CHILD IS NOT THERE, YOU
CANNOT CORRECT IT IN THE FUTURE.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING?
THERE'S ISSUES THAT YOU CAN DEAL
WITH, IS MY CHILD BEHIND IN
READING, WE CAN DO ALL THE OTHER
THINGS IF YOUR CHILD IS WITH
YOU.
IF YOUR CHILD IS NO LONGER WITH
YOU BECAUSE SOMEONE DID NOT WANT
TO WEAR A MASK TO PROTECT THEM,
THERE'S NO AMOUNT OF CORRECTING
AND NOTHING BEYOND THAT POINT
THAT YOU CAN DO.
>> I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU THAT
FOR THE MOST PART PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO DO THE MASKS IN SCHOOLS
ARE DOING IT BECAUSE THEY THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO BY
PUBLIC HEALTH AND I'M NOT
DISPUTING ANYONE MOTIVES.
I THINK MORE COLLABORATION WITH
THE PARENTS AND LESS MAKING THEM
FE